hi Dave how are you hey good how are you
good have you got your tickets for the
Atlanta event no I don't would you like
to come as my guest
sure all right I'll give you someone we
get through how can I help
oh they would be great thank you
actually um with me our daughter is
currently in college she's 25 and right
now we support her giving her five
hundred dollars a month for just wanted
you know her cost and when she graduates
in May of 2016
she will need a vehicle and she's
currently borrowing us mother's so we
don't want to give her the vehicle you
really want to keep it but we know that
she won't be able to afford to buy one
and we don't want to see her take out a
loan so the truck is worth five thousand
and we thought of giving her a
graduation present flash bluffing of 35
birla see ya thirty five hundred which
puts it at fifteen hundred that she
would pay us and monthly payments per
year because we know I don't we're just
assuming maybe $100 would be enough
service what you want to keep the truck
we do but we're just we don't she
already has $14,000 in school and we
just were just trying to maybe like I
said when you're putting her in fifteen
hundred dollars in debt to you what's
the difference
Wow that is true but it's not
accomplishing the goal let's put her in
a car she can afford something else is
she working
no she seasons she's in full-time school
while I'm sure why is she working well
she's doubling her classes she didn't
look double did you know she's getting
her undergrad
she can't even graduate with a
psychology degree four-year mm-hmm okay
25 years old yeah 25 she kind of did you
know if you tried this and that and then
decided yeah and what she wanted to do
but that she look for a job no cuz she's
in school
no I'm talking about like when she gets
out of school what's she gonna do oh
yeah she's gonna look for a job yeah and
she hasn't yet though no snow she will
probably come like early spring so good
job what are you gonna do with a psych
undergrad well she's got a different
option she's really good at you know she
uses you know research and wisdom and
all that kind of thing so she she
already has that figured out I guess
like what her options would be but like
I said we just don't I don't know we're
working today how many hours is she
carrying well I don't know she's maxed
out the max you can do I don't know off
an only a max you can do per year no
appurtenant her whatever they're called
credits yeah yeah so she she doesn't
have any time to breathe none oh that's
not that let me help you with this
that's not true okay yeah you can carry
a full load you have time to breathe I
promise you she has time to breathe it's
not not compared to maybe some of her
fellow students are carrying a half load
and loafing the rest of time but she's
got time to breathe I've graduated three
children through college and so I know
the mythology versus the actual facts
when you get down into there and that by
the way I went to school too and you
probably did too so that's the greatest
con in the world that a full load is a
full-time job
that's not true but aside from that I
know I'm not putting her in debt to you
ever I'm not putting her in debt to
anyone she needs to buy something we can
afford so I would either give her the
truck or I would sell the truck and put
1,500 in your pocket and give her a
$3,500 car oh okay I get it
one of the two but I don't want her to
be further in debt because she doesn't
even have her her job lined up yet and
she's already got 14,000 in debt coming
out but and you guys are supporting her
very well I would challenge you to think
it maybe she could work something
part-time this semester and next
semester and saved some money towards
the purchase of a car and maybe you
match her on whatever she comes up with
that might give her some incentive to do
some more work I know she thinks she's
overloaded but honey gene overloaded
this is the Dave Ramsey show